So now we know how to read
the intercepts off of the graph.
But we also learned something else
interesting here, at the x-intercept,
the y value is always 0, and at the
y-intercept, the x value is always 0.
I think we can use that to do
something pretty interesting.
What these facts are going to let us
do is find the intercepts of a graph
without actually seeing the graph,
just by looking at the equation.
Let's say we had this equation.
I can find the x-intercept of this
equation by setting the y value to 0 and
then solving for x.
So in this case 2x + 0 = 6,
divide both sides by 2, and x = 3.
So it looks like
the x-intercept would be at 3,0.
And to find the y-intercept, well,
I know the x values going to be 0.
So I'm going to start
in my same equation.
But now I'm going to set x = 0 and
solve for y.
Well, 2 times 0 is just 0,
this tells me that y = 6 which
means the y-intercept is at 0,6.
Then once I have my points, I can draw
a line to connect them, and there,
I have my graph.
Maybe you can answer a question for
me now.
What are the intercepts of 3x- 2y = 12?
Enter the x and y-intercept as x,
y coordinate pairs.
[BLANK_AUDIO]